hey what's up internet so today we're
going to go over another after effects
quick tip for you guys and it's going to
be over fading in and fading out instead
of usual zero to 100 opacity like this
bam mind blowing
yes bam
instead we're going to use something
called a luma mat using fractal noise to
make a more uneven and disrupted sort of
fade in like this
what gear is it
be gone
see how interesting that is you can do
this for anything let's go check it out
all right let's do this tutorial so i've
already set up the project file here i
just dragged in the footage and then i
also managed to get a clean plate which
is just you know masked here super
simple as you can see here i have the
clean plate on and then it fades out to
reveal carmichael who was standing there
the whole time and then it fades back on
to make him go away but if we take that
a step forward we can use what's called
a luma mat so if i make a white solid
hit ctrl y and if you set this track
matte option down here on your clean
plate set it to a luma matte it'll
source whatever layer it is above it the
the luminance value that means basically
anything from of zero value brightness
whiteness to a 100 darkness
or
blackness
pure white will make the layer below it
completely opaque anything that is pure
black will make the layer below it pure
invisible and if you set it to luma
inverted mat it'll just make that
backwards it depends on your scenario if
i go to my white solid here and i change
the opacity to zero it fades in the
layer underneath now this is where we
actually get tricky and i'm going to go
up here to the effects and presets panel
and type in fractal noise i'm going to
drop that onto our layer here i'm going
to turn it back on because whenever you
set it to a luma matte it automatically
disables the layer above it but we're
going to look at it for a moment so i'm
going to turn it back on
voila it's just a standard
run-of-the-mill fractal cotton ball
noise nothing fancy about it you can
change the evolution which is
essentially just the seed for randomness
contrast brightness and darkness and
this is where the key part of the effect
comes from right away i'm going to set
this to really really bright set a
keyframe on the brightness go forward
like maybe a second or so drop that down
to really really dark into black and
what just happens here is a transition
from pure white to pure black so if we
turn this layer back off and see our
clean plate during this transition
you'll notice it kind of fades in with a
bit of a pattern to it but it's not very
strong right now so let's go ahead and
enhance that we can choose all different
types of noises can choose strings
that's weird let's go with that your
complexity set that to eight you can
adjust all these settings as much as you
want you can even animate the evolution
from zero to 100 so you get like this
weird stringy motion another thing i
like to do is actually crank the
contrast when you crank the contrast
you'll have to adjust your in and out
brightness points but that's okay so if
you turn our
fractal solid back off
we'll see that we now have this
interesting little
transition and you can do things like
add a mosaic to it to make it all blocky
i did that for the
superheroes versus gaming heroes video
for the energy sword that pops out it's
all very like digitized and sharp edges
you can apply this to anything the lord
of the rings putting on the ring of
power to disappear if you have any
questions or
you want to see anything else leave a
comment we do read all of them can't
promise we'll write responses to all of
them but we do see all the comments so
it's always great when you write them
and if you have any ideas for others let
us know in the meantime
you know
eat your veggies
carmichael you're getting really close
hey